Microsoft wants to enable engineers to
build intelligent control systems we
want engineers to build these systems
using their subject matter expertise
without requiring any high background my
name is Sarah Glockner I'm a principal
program manager at Microsoft's
autonomous systems division I have
always been excited about the power of
artificial intelligence and the kind of
systems you can build it
when using advanced AI approaches I'm
using a math work Simulink model to
teach an AI system to replace an
existing control system within the
simulation model it's a very simple
assimilation model in casual it's called
carpol the AI has to learn how to move
the cart so the pole stays upright we
are modeling the plant including all the
mathematical equations that are
representing the physical system of the
model and then we have developed a
bonsai block and the bonsai rockets it's
also in charge of managing the
connection back into the service that we
have built on the azure cloud that is
the AI training and teaching service
that takes over actions within the
simulation model and receives state
information back from the simulation
model so it's wired up in a way where
the action from our block feeds directly
into the plant and then it receives back
information from the model itself based
on how the state of the model is
changing so it's four variables position
velocity angle and rotation data then
are being fed back into the bonsai block
moving over to the MATLAB command prompt
in a few seconds we will see how the
MATLAB now is connecting back to our
service the user interface that users
are seeing when they are training these
systems using our service you're landing
in an environment where you can actually
see how the progress of the training is
doing we have achieved some results but
not completed yet and you could also see
that on the representation in the visual
model
how the balancing still works the
maximum that can be achieved here is a
reward of 1,000 let me go on and show
you how we allow the user to actually
teach our system what the environment
actually is all about and what the
optimal behavior is that we want the AI
system to learn the two pieces that are
incredibly important are always what is
the simulation environment made of what
is the state information that is
available to the AI service and what are
the actions that should be controlled by
the AI system in our case position
velocity angle and rotation and the
action is we can either move the block
to the right or to the left the AI agent
needs to learn and understand was the
action it took the right action or was
it not the right action and in this case
the reward function that describes that
optimal behavior it will get a reward if
it was able to keep the pole upright for
one step and it will then humilate these
rewards over time which basically means
it will learn how to optimize the reward
and it will get a single reward point
for every time step where the pole was
upright simulations are basically data
providers for the AI agent so instead of
using data sets as you would do in
supervised learning scenarios in
reinforcement learning we are using
simulations to provide these data
samples and the interesting part here is
that you see that we are not just having
one simulator connected to the system
but we have now 17 connected to the
system and it works in a way where we
are running in one roll crew and we are
adding another 16 that we are running in
parallel using the azure cloud you see
good progress see also on the right
we're getting close to 1,000 so very
shortly we actually have a fully trained
neural net that is able to balance the
pole you can always connect or create a
graph that shows you what kind of data
is actually being exchanged between the
simulation environment and the AI
training environment so I'm switching to
a different version that I trained
before I can manage my brain versions
they are now you can see that the neural
net has converged that's how we call
that the
training has reached 1,000 that is the
maximum possible reward that can be
achieved and you have basically now a
neural net that can provide for any
given state an optimal action based on
your definition of a year award function
using our autonomous systems platform
engineers of any background can solve
complex control problems using AI
through a unique combination of machine
teaching reinforcement learning and
simulation
[Music]